(upbeat music)
- [Dr. Mike] Hey everybody! Dr. Mike here.
Everyone has their morning routine,
and I'd like to show you what mine is like
to prepare me for a hectic
day in the hospital.
The first thing I like
to do in the morning
when I open my eyes, is to grab
a glass of warm lemon water.
The warm water allows
your digestive system to
improve its circulation and
get ready to start the day.
Also, lemons contain two great nutrients,
potassium and a little bit of vitamin C,
which is great, especially
if the night before
you had a great workout or
maybe even had an extra drink of alcohol
that you shouldn't have had.
(upbeat music)
The second thing I like to do when
I wake up in the morning is make my bed.
It sounds like a small task,
but your brain loves
achieving goals big or small,
and setting a small goal
that is easily achievable
allows your brain to set bigger
goals throughout the day.
Most importantly,
who doesn't like coming
home to a clean bed?
Rox,
Come on,
you're late with the fives.
A great trick to waking up in the morning,
that is even better than caffeine,
is to take a cold shower.
You don't need to take a full cold shower,
you can start with warm and move up
and do 10 seconds of cold.
Just like this.
Science says it could
even improve testosterone
and improve circulation and focus.
AAAAHH!
Gotta get dressed,
that's a no brainer,
everyone is doing it.
Sometimes I'll need to wear scrubs
if I'm working the Emergency Room
or the Obstetric Department.
Sometimes I'll need to put on a suite
if I'm doing a formal presentation,
or seeing patients inside my clinic.
I like my scrubs to be very fitted.
A lot about being a doctor is
about your non-verbal cues,
how you present yourself.
I also like my scrubs to
be bright colored, happy,
and really show that confident energy that
I like to give to my
patients every single day.
Another crucial part of my morning routine
is an easy five minute warm up.
I'm not telling you to do
a full exercise regimen
when you wake up,
but take a few minutes,
move your body around,
it will do wonders for your concentration,
your flexibility,
and most importantly,
it will prevent injury.
My favorite part of the morning is
taking this little husky out for a walk.
Roxy obviously needs her
daily morning exercise,
but it's also a great time for me
to do some self reflection,
leave my cell phone behind,
enjoy the beauty of the city,
maybe get a little vitamin
D if it's sunny out,
but ultimately I find
that walk is a great way
for me to meditate and get
ready for the rest of my day.
Last but not least, got
to get some food in me
before I head out to the hospital.
Proteins, complex carbohydrates,
great ways to start your day.
Get some eggs, whole wheat
bread, maybe some oatmeal,
leave you feeling full and energized
throughout your entire work day.
I also like to grab a
quick snack like a banana,
get some vitamins in,
because the hospital can be a crazy place
you need a quick snack.
So, I'm ready to start my day.
If you do something interesting
in your morning routine
that you would like to share with me,
leave it in the comments.
If there is something you
would like to know more
about your morning routine,
leave it in the comments.
If you haven't hit subscribe already,
hit that button now.